what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg and John here today to watch the
final episode of secret Invasion today and
before you guys ask where koi is we have no
idea where he's at based off of knowing koi he is
more than likely asleep right now and traditional
koi fashion he is not fulfilling his contractual
obligation and is missing the final episode of
the Disney plus Marvel series that's just the
way it's tradition koi operates just like at
our Comic-Con panel he was nowhere to be seen for
the first half of that entire time he got there
eventually so who knows maybe he'll show up for
the last five minutes we'll actually Miss Marvel
you missed the final episode and then he was here
for it so I'm the only reliable one around here
yes truly guys I did want to say a thank you
to everyone who did attend our Comic-Con panel
uh it's some of the compliments that we got even
from the tech team there uh where they came out
to us while the other battle was going on it
was it was so unbelievably kind what everyone
was saying to us and it was such a blast with
that in mind too you guys might have seen I
was drinking G fuel when I was there and there's
a reason why G fuel is arguably the best brand
that real rejects has ever partnered with yeah
guys there's a special code in the description
box to get yourself uh discount on select tubs
there I think every single flavor we've ever had
has been delicious and I I rely on them they
got me through Comic-Con they get me through
most days of the week I certainly mean that so
thank you to G fuel for sponsoring this video
and I shout you guys out even when you're not
sponsored for a reason because I I really do love
them it's a great way to support the channels
making yourself some g-fuel with that in mind
leave a like on this video also be sure to check
us out on patreon as well where you'll catch the
full interaction watch along for this thank
you to all who have joined us let's get to it
all right let's do this let's do this 20 minute
episode of finale where nothing will be rushed
purple squirrel Blood on the wall
koi is it the first time you
call this number in years
I have dialed this number a million times [__]
no you'll be coming oh all right I'll uh I'll
let you go now oh you don't have to if you don't
want to darling go to her take care of yourself
Priscilla will return I'll get the
romance I keep begging for oh yeah
not bad actually a cool shot
yeah it's a really cool shot
they couldn't tell that from the distance
damn Fury how'd you set that [__]
up how long was that car going for
our Republic orchestrated by the skrulls and
the Russians who are giving them safe haven
discussions negative I suggest you move on to
doing what it is you were summoned here to do
present the president of the United States with
his options to Russia you know Roadie you've had
a lot more propaganda in your language lately
the rhetoric is really through the roof what
are we looking at here Colonel Rhodes I love
that Dermot Moroni showed up to have like five
lines in this whole show yeah now sir if I may
I've taken the Liberty to prepare a rough copy
of your remarks to the nation carpet bomb they
need your leadership they need to understand
who's responsible for this and it's the
Russians 100 it's the Russians it's the
Russians Russians Russians Russians it's always
the Russians and a little bit of the Scrolls
I think this is Gaia I think this
is Gaia yeah it's Gotta Be Gaia
foreign
radiation poisoning
God guy is really in character
this episode's bringing back a little more of that
cinematography I was admiring in the beginning
star strong and strong baby you have to get
him out of there Fury's headed straight for you
smart he wants Ritz and stop before the
bomb it's launched move the president now
oh maybe she's Gaia they're all Gaia foreign
[Laughter]
locked away looks like it's just you and me fury
I need a lozenge no more protection for you how
about a drink instead I'll do the trick yeah
I put a lot of sugar in it for you
it was Ant-Man using my skin like a costume a
costume Fury do not recognize this skin this face
this was the first human I killed an Abercrombie
model I killed him because you told me to
oh wow ah it just doesn't stop everything's
your fault I killed him and I killed so many
more and everyone I killed took a little piece
out of my heart blames him for everything I'm
supposed to be like Talos and put my trust in you
you pimped us Fury oh and when you were done with
us you threw us away so first I'm gonna kill
you no no he's in the Marvels impossible so
I am absolutely clear about this Fury you look
at me look at me look at me and the massacres
and the wildfires and the imminent removal of
humans from their habitat that is all you that
is some good acting they were condemned to Die
the day I realized you weren't a man of your word
it's okay for squirrels to go to therapy [Music]
betterscrolls.com you're right I I failed you
I failed you I'm sorry I knew the only way
for me to keep my end of the bargain was to
build your home here why didn't you do it oh
it's easier to save the lives of a billion
people weird audio than it is to change their
hearts and Minds sure the last thing I felt
before I flake dog flaked off relief
sure relief that I didn't have to
fight anymore that I finally had a way
out I believe you actually said [__]
we're spam doctrinated I should have taught
you never who's doing this killing I've decided
give you what you want Carol Danvers DNA no way
whoa take your powers go to some other planet
wipe out some of the species I don't give a damn
really call off the strike and save your people
oh I think the radiation's in your brains mate
what's the ultimate plan here Fury
coughing is an act
you have a war machine suit and
you're protecting the president who
was just attacked by what you telling
people are Russian and scroll forces
put it in the crisper whoa damn like everyone's
name is here Rockstar's gonna have a great time
yeah it's the entire End Game Cast no checking
behind the doors you really are a scroll I don't
know what it is you think you're doing
just Jules back into the hallway go on
has she been doing all this herself
that's how it appears right now
because I mean she's like invisible yeah
maybe she got powers we don't know about
Fury is going to get power yeah what are you doing
makes you buffer goodness
it does look like abomination
yeah what is happening
what powers did you get Hulk Hulk Fury
do that AI music
oh there you go it was a Gaia H well done girl
oh Nick Fury really was going yeah sure
put that together right when we realized
you killed my mother my father
prepare to die I have the magnet
ah Drax arm yeah
I think he did sprout an Abomination arms
[Music] oh my goodness phasing guy ghost
is a court group
wow this Atari
pretty much Atari Frost giant
maybe I better get Frost Giant
grow
dozens of world officials along with Colonel Rose
they're positive the president isn't a scroll
happen anymore
oh this is like more secret Invasion because
a lot of powers are adapting yeah and they're
doing them like quadrants of
the body just stay the course
right and all our enemies will be gone yeah yeah
get got it it's a great argument there roadie
Zion [Music]
power battle
sleep did he have a Thanos arm
purple arm
this is pretty cool I'm all of a sudden excited
for your ass I hope she doesn't die now [Music]
yes
just like them that's a good
thing yeah damn oh my God
and just like that he's dead
yep so long compelling villain
did really make much of a moment
out of that but okay so who's that
yo whoa right the forehead
oh it's fine Jesus somebody give me the
phone that there's parts of that fight that
I thought were really cool it is also what
the She-Hulk finale was making fun it is I
wonder if he'll regenerate or something does
the maybe flip that on its ear a little bit
real man
just the actor himself I'm an agent what
you've been held hostage for a long time for
how long exactly I totally forgot about oh
yeah they might be down there yeah all right the
terrorists responsible shape-shifting alien-born
species known as skrulls but they're not all bad
presenting to Congress for immediate emergency
authorization a bill that designates all off-world
born species enemy combatants oh boy and we will
kill every last one of you that is not what
Nicholas Fury was hoping for he is return to
form without making a moment out of it he just
walked into frame yep he's back cued the music
the trailer had more of a moment
don't worry he's still got like five minutes left
gee they can still put punctuation on this walking
through I know who I am when you're not here is
when you come back that I start to wonder did you
fall in love with me yes or the face that puts
you at ease The Fetish is what he filmed love
you Priscilla I love your ass you can find a
way to forgive me you know where to find me
I'm sorry is that the direction of
that series is done so flat so weird
we meet at last oh complimentary colors opposition
you'll need resources to fight this war that
Ritson has launched on your people and I can give
them to you the British versus Americans well
let's be sure not to repeat the mistakes of Talos
and fury and leave love and friendship out of this
I will use you and you will use me together
we'll make this planet safe for both our
people 50 Shades of Gaia yeah dude Gaia and
Sonia will return what the hell is all this
this is how enemy got so good what are they
gonna do you took a bad situation and made it
worse oh no one-term president stuff that's real
Harrison Ford is replaced it up now oh my God damn
oh geez did not say that [__] wow now
you got dumbass Vigilantes killing innocent
humans too oh this is Bleak when it
hasn't killed himself oh boy oh we
needed more of her she's awesome if you truly
care about the Scrolls get them off my planet
your planet
[Music]
how long do you think we're gonna forget about
this scroll plot points [Laughter] hold a minute
hard to just hold this thing still she
gonna go with him yes do it go to him
whoa this is so like E.T close encounter
[__] right romantic Encounters of the
Third Kind Priscilla Vara now that humans know
we're among them I'd like to use my birth name
good news from saber Cree said they opened peace
talks with the scrolls are they setting up Marvels
which friend reached out to you Chris said they're
open to peace talks what do Scrolls call good luck
bad luck stop it it's a good thing I don't know
man my hell yeah with this you know this peace
Summit crease Summit I'm no good with people
you are you've got your own way oh cool I'm
sick of it I guess the scroll thing is going to
actually factor into the marbles could do please
come with me
Come With Me Now
I'll help you get started huh but then I've
got to get back oh my work is here darling
he arrived alone and now he's leaving
with someone yeah full character Arc
um I just wanted to tell you that
that I love you as I am ah only
two which is best character this
year 100. yeah they want honor
look how far we've come
oh it's like cover art I like it I like
the way this looks actual romantic moment
hell out of here
here they go there they go
oh what a great last shot
to become one
show's over and I guess agent Maria
Hill just is dead that was the first
episode that said it didn't have
her as a guest star Moment of Truth
moment okay drumroll koi was asleep
you got something back what'd he say
damn it man you missed so much could have pointed
out the one or two power sets that we did not
properly call well I'm sure screen Crush heavy
spoilers and you rock stars are gonna have fun
breaking down and deciphering every single power
that we saw in that fight scene uh I don't that's
that's not what we do what we're gonna do is give
our uh analysis A Commentary of course a review of
the episode and factoring our experience of the
entire season as a whole as well that's what we
want to do today and I'll let John go first
since John tends to be the nicer one always
out of everyone who ever comes on this channel
that's right kind Johnny uh you know this was a
a decent finale in my eyes there were certainly
this exemplifies a lot of the things that the
show has been up until now there are a lot of
really nice scenes I think this is one of the
better ish overall episodes but you know
the season as a whole has had this quality
of like yeah certain parts are really cooking
certain things are very intriguing certain ins
uh certain relationships are easy to really
latch on to and then other things feel a bit
perfunctory and feel a bit kind of rushed and
you know sort of by the numbers or or at least
like they could have used an extra ounce of
inspiration or oomph or something and no well
I know I'm saying I'm I'm the hot takes today all
right I'm saying what no one's uh uh brave enough
to say there are Wars there are worse finales of
this on the Disney Plus show oh certainly more
disappointing ones I would say yeah and there
are probably more inconsistent shows than this
one like ultimately I liked no this was on a
steady deconsistent it's on a steady decline
naturally God it was on a gradual slope down
to being fine yeah yeah yeah Blended on a fine
note yeah and it's like I don't want the the
response to this to teach the wrong message
because I really like what this was going for and
by extension I think the easiest Marvel series
up until this point to compare this to would be
Falcon in the Winter Soldier and that was another
show where I was like I really like what you guys
are going for and obviously that was hampered by
other circumstances but you know both of them are
shows where you're like ah you you got close to
something really interesting and cool but you
kind of you know settled for like yeah you know
a surface level depiction of this kind of yeah
conflict and again I don't want to keep harping
this point but in a post and or world you just
know that it's possible to reach those Heights
of like oh all the cool sci-fi [__] that we want
out of this franchise plus real world ruminations
and you know gray areas of socio-political
economic Espionage and things like that
um I like this as a as a wrap up to especially I
mean Nick Fury and Priscilla is like the best part
of the show named zafara Vara sorry I didn't
mean to get a dead name and um but yeah like
that's easily the heart and soul of the show
I liked some of the wrap-ups in terms of you
know finally getting to see some of those Powers
come to the screen but for every piece of Praise I
have to lump on this as there's also a gripe or a
complaint or a knit to pick you don't have to John
you could be the guy who likes everything okay
I love this you guys best finale best show most
consistent content out of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe quote me on that uh yeah I mean it was
really obvious that it was going to be Gaia there
uh did it make sense to me that Nick Fury would
show up for the fight I'm really conflicted about
a lot of that uh like the fight in and of itself
and the one I have a dichotomy about it and the
great words oh duplicitous I do because there's
so many things I liked about it and then there's
so many things contextually that I'm like but
wait a minute then that's where I'm really coming
from here like I really thought gravic's speech
the entire time he was lamenting his Sorrows his
pains upon Nicholas Fury and all the blame for
his actions are just being projected onto him the
entire time and it was it was a really impactful
moment and the first like 10 minutes or so of
this episode I I did think they were okay they're
going back a little bit more to what I was really
loving about this show uh within the first two let
me get to the first three episodes like the things
that I still loved about the first three episodes
and and then of course the speech
and Nick Fury is giving back
but the fact that it's Gaius the one who's
saying it I'm wondering what my takeaway is
is that supposed to be Nick Fury's Arc or is
that Gaia coming to an understanding finally
you know of this is what uh that her dad like why
her dad believes so much in Nick and now she sees
the perspective and now she's on that side is she
did she have this conversation with Nick Fury and
now she's like my last time before I flaked away
I'm like was this a thing you discussed with Nick
yeah between the last episode of this one Nick
was like here's everything you gotta say because
she's not like cerebrally hooked up to him and
you know the way how these other scrolls are
so to me I'm like who's our does this belong
to right now is this a Gaia Arc is this a Nick
Arc is this anyone's Ark and that's why I
I feel conflicted about that moment because
it was really apparent that it was going to
be Gaia and then the plan in and of itself I
thought was a little ridiculous like that could
have gone so awry that could have gone I I don't
think that was thought out at all of what she did
I'm gonna give him this and we're gonna battle it
out you can't count so much on him being okay with
Nick being in the accelerator machine the reactor
whatever it is as well and it's like he could
have easily been like no beyond that it counts on
the fact that she would like they don't know what
powers they're gonna get yeah and that's and while
I think there's something so cool contextually
about everything everyone having this amalgamation
of a billion different Power sets that are all
coming through and it's cool to see on screen
and for someone who read the secret Invasion comic
book I'm like all right now we're doing a little
bit of secret Invasion stuff like we've had the
whole paranoia thing down of who's a scroll and
now we're doing the element of watching a a uh
a scroll adapt Powers now they're just combining
it all in like two characters right and you know
visually it it wasn't bad to me you know I I think
it's Marvel especially uh it's an easy thing to
knock at when it comes to their visuals and I'm
like come on we've we've seen worse oh sure we've
seen worse and all things considered I'm like
this is pretty cool like there's something pretty
cool about it but like I said the the idea behind
the plan is a little too far-fetched to me and it
seemed like an excuse to go down that Disney plus
throughout that that that She-Hulk directly makes
fun of for what the shows do yeah to get to the
point with big VFX fight scene thing especially
with two characters who have all these personal
charge Stakes pointed at each other to just
culminate in yeah like a smash them up battle
and then graphic just gets murked on the spot no
you know unceremonious death I mean like you get
the speech but that's pre-fight you need a moment
after the fight to send them off at least his
death was so on what was so lackluster uh the way
that went down just an easy beam to the chest you
know like I thought it was such a weak death scene
especially for such a great like a really well
written and well-performed villain yeah I thought
I was really I I did not I I did not like that
and what I don't like in in situations like this
especially is them learning Powers is them going
I'm looking at it all right I got it I just
can just imagine what to do yeah and and I I
I generally don't like that at all like no there
should be some figuring out of what what to do you
both even Captain America when he's first running
in that movie he's like well I'm running yeah yeah
like and they're each being overwhelmed with
an influx of like every conceivable power from
everybody who showed up in the end game battle
pretty much so yeah I mean the fact that they're
immediately jumping to like I got four quadrants
in my body all different powers and I'm wielding
them dual and it's no problems whatsoever I think
it's really cool I thought there was like cool
parts to it overall the Gaia character um I think
Emilia Clarke she really I think she showed up I
think Amelia Clarke uh really did her her best I
don't feel like the show ultimately gave her much
to do in the end uh I I think that her character
was underserved it's Amelia Clarke who I do think
is a really great actress and I I wish that they
gave her more substance or something more to chew
on versus what we ultimately got here giving her
moments to Nick Fury yeah and giving it I don't
know that give her stoicness you know and it's
an interesting thing to leave off on her with
with her and Olivia Coleman and like them teaming
up and I'm just gonna have this like the the most
ultimate super scroll the only truly I mean she
seems like one of the most powerful beings in the
whole MCU beat like everyone yeah Captain Marvel
Powers Thanos powers and she's overpowered power
uh Frost giant Frost Beast Frost giant like frost
Giants and Thanos and and you've got everyone and
everyone characters who haven't even been named
in the universe yet massively overpowered yeah
massively overpowered yeah from like the good uh
from the hero and villain sides alike yeah it's
it's it's a little ridiculous and you thought
people were like Captain Marvel over powerful
guy you know like that is so that's so crazy you
can see what what she can do um cool to behold
the image the imagery was very cool like again
that was the most excited like I think her best
character scene was in an episode or two ago with
Vara when they are bonding that's like easily the
most Vivid Gaia character moment but in this
episode I mean you know I I did like that they
even though the Nick Fury thing is kind of
confusing like her getting to at least talk
about the release of death I thought was kind
of like a moment where they sort of overlap and
you're like okay I can see where you two have sort
of a similar experience here but perhaps but yeah
um written I think that so much of the interesting
nuanced commentary where I was crediting this
show so much for not being a black and white
conversation suddenly everything devolves into
a black and white conversation and it just becomes
a dick yeah it was written especially I'm like yes
I think like is that the likely response if we're
going off a real world situations of course uh
if we're if we're thinking topical of course yeah
absolutely I do think it the way the show handles
this like slingshot effect though especially
when Nick Fury was the one who saved his life
and Olivia Coleman does it's both Olivia
Coleman and Nick Fury there I'm like what
was the conversation there because clearly they
must have had a conversation with the president
that did not communicate to him of like actually
it's a little there's some bad ones and there's
some good ones just look how there's some good
humans and some bad humans you know well and
Talos you know Taylor saved his life saved his
life and it seemed like something that Nick
would go out of his way to communicate the fact
that they don't even have this conversation pop
up in the show is really upsetting to me yeah uh
when I'm like that was the whole freaking point
of Taylor saving him that was the entire Point
yeah so it was death goes unjust in that moment
um so that's annoying to me there's a lot of
problems I got with this film I'm not gonna
lie I got a lot of issues yeah and funny enough
for for I feel like we've all been sitting here
on a lot of these lately going man I wish they
would like kill off some characters or make some
steaks and I feel like this series killed off a
few characters and yet I feel like in some ways
those characters were less you know killed for
a great impact or some kind of massive change
and more sort of slighted because like yeah if
this is the last we're going to see of Talos or
Maria Hill yeah like I don't think It ultimately
served the entirety or or some big purpose to do
that especially if we're not going to come back
around and go hey this guy sacrificed himself for
you let's get some kind of Memorial now this
whole fight is done for Talos or something
because it's a character I feel like people
like and have been endeared to and it's one
of The Shining parts coming out of Captain Marvel
through this yeah and I mean even Maria Hill like
I you know I always got excited to see her she
gets a prominent presence in the first episode
and then once we move past that it's just kind of
done well then they had her funeral and he said he
talks with her mom and you think there's going to
be some type of top of episode two yeah you think
it's going to be some personal uh Conquest that
Nick Fury is setting out on it does not go that
yeah that's where it ends off on so okay I I I
get the set up it's like it seemed like they were
just in a hurry to get to the plot set up for
where this girl's going next that segues into
Marvels where obviously the cree are going to be
in Marvels and maybe they will actually address
the whole scroll thing which is a big deal first
Korean squirrels to possibly get the hell along
you know that's a big deal um uh and and I I hope
the movie does it I I hope the movie shows that
uh or unless like we solved it off screen yeah
I don't know what they're gonna do but cool fine
um I I guess I'm excited for that uh
but yeah I mean I liked uh Nick Fury and
vara's final moments here there are things
that there's whole this whole thing with I
I can't believe in the trailer they had the whole
thing with the reveal of Nick Fury will eventually
come back to being you know him yeah and then here
just like walks in the house yeah like don't make
a moment out of it yeah and I can it's itching for
that so much I'm like you could have it just treat
it like it's nothing yeah well yeah and it's torn
between I think it's torn between being those two
different kinds of shows the version where it's
like badass comeback finally I've returned to my
full form versus going like understated and more
intimate with it and I feel like here it postures
the intimacy and mostly leads with that leg hey
kind of energy and then in moments like that we'll
like randomly go flat and I like I can't tell if
stuff was retooled or if there were just certain
things that you know they were more enthusiastic
about than others when it came to like really
bringing these moments to life on set like it is
like an odd show because it doesn't feel as like
Jagged and inconsistent as some shows do but
it will travel from feeling quite inspired and
quite Punchy to feeling like again perfunctory
a little bit or sort of a workman-like I mean
I I like the uh the darkness of the final moments
where you're seeing Humanity you start going crazy
and just like taking things into their own hands
yeah because it's all like national television and
um it feels real it's just like it's just so kind
of harsh and Stark and just like oh wow like those
people just got mowed down yeah yeah no it's a TV
studio at the same time I do think that the movie
is paid the show's pacing uh undercuts the moment
so much it just felt like it had to move so fast
that it couldn't really sink its teeth it tried
to do you have two really long First episodes like
what what mandate was ordered yeah who decides
these things and why are all the show like why
why is there a consistent issue with the lengths
of these shows well it jarringly became shorter
yeah it jarringly became like kicked into like
a higher gear it went from like almost an hour
long for the first two which I really liked both
and and I know there are people like I saw people
in the comments in the last episode going this
is probably my favorite episode uh and I'm I'm
that's again that's good for you guys if it if
it is your favorite episode uh uh I I cannot say
that anything has reached the heights of the first
two following this I I think this is better than
episode four and five I I like this more than
episode four then I think I do I don't know I
really don't I don't even give a [__] honestly
uh I I don't know I'm sorry I I doubt it one two
six three four five one two and we're great and
three was the second one below them and then after
that it's a mixed bag to me uh for four five and
six uh so yeah this this was um overall the finale
of of it all that I thought was very much I still
thought it was a mess and as while there were some
exciting moments to be had I still thought it was
very messy I didn't dislike it to the point of
do you see the thing is like when I think
about Moon night and I think about Hawkeye
uh I remembered the penultimates really liking
yes you know yeah being like whoa this could
make maybe maybe like nail yeah and then the
finales I was like oh [__] wrap this all up
yeah yeah we're here I was like well the show's
been going downhill for me so yeah I'm not exactly
disappointed us with like 50 minutes I'm like I
had fun I'm not going to think about it ever again
probably to me this is like the most consistent of
the inconsistent shows because the ways in which
it is inconsistent are quite consistent across
the show itself like I I like the tone in the
atmosphere and and most everything I think that
gets so lost though over time like the same work
remains but yeah all that stuff gets lost no yeah
I'm not gonna pretend like this is a show that is
marked to me by the the potential it's like there
are moments when it's hitting the potential there
are a lot of moments when it's not I like the
general veneer of what the show is and I hope
that they don't decide not to pursue this flavor
in the future because it does feel a bit different
and it does feel in that more again Espionage not
to everyone always pulls Winter Soldier and this
doesn't feel exactly like that but this feels
yeah like oh the kind of government conspiracy
side of all this superhero and uh you know infused
World um and I like that they spend the time and
energy to do that I just yeah I I wish they could
iron out the consistency Factor because this is
yeah it's like when it's flat it's not terrible
and it's not like completely out of line with
what's come before it's just yeah it's just
doesn't have the room to breathe well guys uh
that those are my thoughts um I if you don't
really want to watch the show I think you just
think out of all the shows this is the one you
could just read what happens in it sure if you
really don't care to watch out of all of them
you can just like look up what happens in it if
you want um so yeah uh what did you think about
it though what are your thoughts we're here to
just share ours uh that's our review so leave your
thoughts down below um hopefully Marvels is good
and hopefully so and we'll see how how much they
factor in humanity worried about Scrolls moving
forward or unless it's just another plot line that
I just introduced and we ultimately don't really
think about it in the end um all right we'll talk
with you all soon thank you to G fuel I gotta edit